un vieux tank à moitié détruit en
bordure de village en ruines vestige de
n'affrontement violent une image
courante presque banale dans l'est de
l'Ukraine
au cours de la première année de guerre
la Russie a perdu plus de 3000 blindés
et Charles d'assaut détruit ou abandonné
une lourde perte mais pas pour tout le
monde
dans cet atelier on travaille
d'arrache-pied du matin au soir pour
réparer retaper des blindés destinés à
l'armée ukrainienne
la plupart d'entre eux viennent de
Russie des prises de guerre saisies à
l'ennemi amené ici pour y être
reconverti des trophées précieux et
utiles pour une armée qui manque de tout
oui
nous voulons sauver nos soldats
d'ibordanostaptuk c'est une énorme
tragédie que beaucoup de nos hommes
soient morts simplement parce qu'il
n'avaient pas de véhicule blindés
ici les chars comme ce T72 de conception
soviétique côtoie les blindés de
transport de troupes et les
lancer-roquettes tout ce qui est
réparable est réparé
on a besoin de chacun de ces temps ici
et maintenant dit-il tous ces véhicules
vont se retrouver au combat sur n'en
avait dit sous la main il partirait dès
maintenant
18 ans de guerre ont jusqu'à présent
était remis à neuf et renvoyé au front
ciseaux sont en cours de réparation
une cinquantaine d'employés travaillent
7 jours sur 7 dans cet atelier ultra
secret situé très près de la ligne de
front et comme service
cognac personne ici n'avait d'expérience
préalable en mécanique militaire
pensez toute la journée sur ces
véhicules qui se sont sans doute
transformés en tombeau pour les soldats
russes les deux mécaniciens ne se
laissent pas émouvoirs
dit-il je suis juste fier de réparer ton
russe pour combattre des Russes et après
un retour à l'expéditeur qui fait
sourire son collègue
c'est merveilleux de savoir qu'on va
retourner leurs armes contre eux
expliquent-ils s'ils sont très fiers des
petits miracles accompli ici au
quotidien les mécaniciens attendent
cependant avec impatience le jour où ils
n'auront plus besoin de rafistoler ces
vieux temps que soviétiques parce qu'ils
auront enfin reçu les blindés et les
chars d'assaut promis depuis si
longtemps par les pays occidentaux ici
Jean-François Bélanger Radio-Canada près
de la ligne de France quelque part dans
le sud-est de l'Ukraine